INTRO:
For anyone who’s been involved in the piracy
community, KickassTorrents or KAT, is one
of the most classic torrenting sites in the
world right up there with The Pirate Bay.
In fact, in 2015, KAT became the most popular
file-sharing website in the world as The Pirate
Bay suffered from legal consequences.
Unfortunately for KAT, their time at the top
didn’t last too long as they started to
experience their own legal issues soon after.
Nevertheless, KAT has remained an extremely
popular option amongst pirates, allowing them
to easily secure their spot in the hall of
infamy.
But as we saw with the Pirate Bay’s founders
and MegaUpload’s founder, prosecutors and
copyright holders aren’t exactly kind to
such founders.
After all, New Zealand sent their anti-terrorist
squad against MegaUpload’s founder, and
Sweden chased the Pirate Bay founders across
the world.
So, there’s no doubt that if you found one
of these sites, you wanna remain anonymous,
and that’s exactly what KAT’s founder
tried to do.
But, prosecutors did eventually find out who
he was, and here’s what happened next.
INCOMPLIANCE:
Taking a look back, the story of KickassTorrents
circles back to a man named Artem Vaulin,
or at least that’s what prosecutors allege.
Ethnically, Artem was Ukrainian, but it looks
like he lived out most of his life in Poland.
It’s not clear when exactly Artem was born,
but given that he was 30 years old when he
was arrested in 2016, we can deduct that he
was born in 1986 or 1987.
Anyway, it looks like Artem was heavily involved
in the piracy community during his teenage
years.
And it didn’t take him very long to switch
from being a user to being a host as Artem
spotted a business opportunity within the
piracy scene.
Similar to YouTube and Instagram, if you hosted
a piracy site, you could display ads that
could drive in revenue, and as you’ll see
later, for KAT, this added up to quite a bit
of revenue.
Considering the potential, Artem didn’t
waste any time and he quickly put his coding
skills to work.
Soon after, in November of 2008, Artem launched
KickassTorrents.
Initially, it looks like Artem tried his best
to avoid issues with the authorities.
KAT proudly claimed that it complied with
the DMCA and that they would remove copyright
infringing torrents as soon as they were notified.
But, in reality, this wasn’t exactly the
case.
Given the context of the site, it didn’t
take long for users to start uploading copyrighted
content, and for copyright holders to start
contacting KAT.
But, they were hit with the same response
every single time.
Greetings, your request has been reviewed,
but cannot be processed due to one or more
of the following reasons.
And most of these reasons were complete and
utter BS.
Reason 4, for example, was that there were
more than 30 torrents mentioned in the claim
email.
If KAT was legitimately trying to comply,
addressing such a claim would be a top priority.
But, KAT was intentionally avoiding claims
with large lists of torrents, probably because
they wanted to draw out the takedown process
and minimize how many torrents they lost with
each takedown.
KAT was able to get away with such outright
incompliance for many years as prosecutors
had much bigger fish to fry.
But as soon as they took down MegaUpload and
The Pirate Bay, prosecutors turned their focus
to KickassTorrents.
ANONYMOUS BATTLE:
Initially, prosecutors started off pretty
light against Kickass.
They didn’t know who was behind the site,
and honestly, I don’t think they cared.
They just wanted to take down the website
and stop the spread of copyrighted material.
So, in February of 2013, they started working
with internet service providers to block access
to KAT.
The High Court in London ordered ISPs to block
people from accessing KickassTorrents and
two other torrent sites.
The ISPs complied and blocked access, but
every time they blocked access to one domain
of Kickass, Kickass just moved to another
domain.
They moved from ka.tt to kickass.to to kickass.so
to kickasstorrents.im to kat.cr and so on
and so forth.
Clearly, prosecutors couldn’t take down
the website through ISPs, but they were able
to force KAT to constantly switch domains.
This meant that most people didn’t know
what the latest domain was off the top of
their heads.
They had to Google KickassTorrents to find
the latest link.
Considering this, the Motion Picture Association
of America or the MPAA decided to work with
Google to take down KAT.
They asked Google to remove the correct kickass
link from Google search results.
They also worked with Steam to prevent the
correct link from being shared on Steam chat.
This strategy was actually decently effective
as this resulted in many pirates stumbling
upon malicious copycat sites that were filled
with malware and viruses.
And this was the perfect excuse for Chrome
and Firefox to completely block access to
KAT even if you had the correct link.
If you tried to access KAT through these browsers
in late 2015, you got a message suggesting
that they blocked access to the site because
they didn’t want you to download a virus.
It’s definitely not because they were being
pressured by copyright holders, they just
wanted to look out for your best interests.
Jokes aside though, we all know why they blocked
access.
In 2016, Chrome and Firefox changed their
excuse to phishing concerns, but soon enough,
neither of them wanted to play these charades
anymore.
So, they opened up access and stepped out
of the way.
By this point, it was clear that KAT wasn’t
just a bug that prosecutors could squash and
move on.
KAT had evolved into being the world’s largest
file-sharing site, so prosecutors decided
that it was time to go for the host.
IRS SPY:
By this point, the FBI had spent years trying
to unsuccessfully takedown KAT, so, they decided
to escalate things to the real top dogs: the
IRS.
Whether it be Al Capone or the Wolf of Wall
Street, it’s clear that the one entity that
you never wanna piss off is the IRS.
Many have pissed off the FBI and gotten away
with it for years, but almost no one has escaped
the IRS, and this was no different for Artem.
The IRS didn’t care that Artem was causing
billions of dollars worth of lost revenue
for copyright holders.
But they did care that Artem was causing losses
for the IRS.
You see, Artem made money off displaying ads
on KAT, and many of these advertisers were
American.
Yet, Artem wasn’t paying sales tax or income
tax on this revenue which was a fatal mistake.
In March of 2016, the IRS got an undercover
agent to inquire about an ad on KAT.
The IRS agent was able to get in contact with
a KAT employee named Mr. White.
Mr. White informed the agent that KAT charges
$300 per ad per day and gave the agent payment
details to a Latvian bank.
The agent went ahead and bought a five-day
ad in order to gain the trust of KAT and potentially
get more details.
Clearly, the IRS had motives behind paying
KAT, but technically, this does also mean
that the IRS supported KAT with $1500.
Anyway, shortly after, the IRS agent contacted
Mr. White again to buy a more expensive ad.
This time he was looking at a banner ad that
cost $1000 to $3200 per day.
It’s not clear if the IRS actually made
the purchase, but they were able to uncover
a new bank account based in Estonia.
Using these details in conjunction with the
Mutual Legal Assitance Treaty, investigators
were able to obtain all the banking records
of these two accounts.
This helped the IRS figure out that Artem
was making bank off of KAT.
At the peak, KAT was pulling in nearly $17
million in annual revenue.
The IRS wanted their cut, and fortunately
for them, the bank accounts led to more clues.
Investigators were able to uncover that the
operation was being hosted out of Chicago
and that the servers were located in Canada.
But, the most important piece of evidence
they found was Artem’s IP address.
They didn’t know who the IP address belonged
to, but the walls were quickly closing in
on Artem.
ARRESTED:
Artem had no idea that prosecutors were so
close to uncovering his identity, so he continued
on with his daily life.
And this included purchasing media from the
iTunes store.
Ironically, the owner of the largest piracy
website in the world was paying for his own
media.
I guess that he felt that if you had the money,
you should pay for it.
I’m not sure, but this ironically ended
up being the root of his demise.
You see, investigators were working with a
bunch of companies to track down the IP address,
one of which was Apple.
And, when Artem made a purchase on the iTunes
store using his Apple ID and his IP address,
prosecutors were quickly able to identify
him.
Facebook was also able to provide evidence
that it was in fact Artem and the same IP
address that was operating KAT’s official
Facebook account.
And on July 20, 2016, the Department of Justice
proudly announced that they had uncovered
the identity of Artem and that Poland police
had arrested him.
They were also able to shut down KAT’s proxy
servers and officially take down the website.
Prosecutors also went ahead and stacked on
every copyright infringement and money laundering
charge they could think of.
And these were pretty severe given that KAT
had distributed $1 billion worth of media.
According to Artem’s lawyer Ira Rothken,
they were looking to charge up to 20 years
for the money laundering and up to 5 years
for each count of copyright infringement.
Rothken did clarify that he highly doubted
that all these convictions would go through,
but worst-case scenario, Artem could’ve
been looking at decades in jail.
To make things worse, Artem was suffering
from extreme back pain and had to be taken
to the hospital.
Artem’s describes that during this trip
to the hospital, he was escorted by four policemen
with machines guns.
And one of the guards told him that they heard
that he committed three murders.
Hearing this, Artem knew that this was going
to be more of a criminal lawsuit than a civil
lawsuit, and he had no intention of sticking
around for the verdict.
KAT TODAY:
As you might’ve already guessed, as soon
as bail was posted, Artem paid the amount
and fled the country.
The bail amount was surprisingly only $108,000.
For someone who was making tens of millions
per year, forfeiting even ten million would’ve
been an easy price to pay for freedom.
But, luckily for Artem, he only had to pay
a little over a hundred thousand.
It’s not clear how exactly Artem left Poland
given that his passport was confiscated, but
given his wealth, I’m sure he was easily
able to find a 1st class smuggler.
Anyway, on August 26, 2020, the Polish Ministry
of Justice confirmed that Artem had fled the
country and that extradition proceedings would
no longer be continuing in Poland.
His legal team withdrew from the case after
they lost contact with Artem, and the Artem
prosecution has since been put on hold.
In other words, as long as Artem is never
caught, the case will never reach a verdict,
and Artem can more or less live a free life
in some non-extraditing country.
As for KickassTorrents today, there are many
sites trying to emulate the original, but
the consensus seems to be that none of them
are as good as the original.
Also, one of the main reasons that Kickass
became so popular was because the Pirate Bay
was taken down, so naturally, everyone flocked
to the second-best option.
But, with the Pirate Bay basically becoming
immortal, there seems to be little need for
anything else.
Still, many miss the glory days of KAT and
the community behind it.
While KAT was not able to become immortal
like the Pirate Bay, there’s the doubt that
KAT will permanently be remembered as a legend
in the piracy community.
Do you guys think it’s moral to pirate?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if Kickass is nostalgic
for you.
And of course, consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.